Media members go nuts over the
realization that Christians actually
exist Rudy Guiliani makes a boo-boo and
beta or Oprah's a diary entry this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so have a lot coming up for
you on today's show we are broadcasting
live from 77 WABC in New York which is
really exciting because if you didn't
know our podcast is also a radio show
then there are two additional live hours
of the radio show later in the day WABC
is one of our flagship stations we're
really excited to be here and thanks so
much to the folks at the station for
allowing us to make it happen I wanna
get to all the news of the day and there
is a lot of news but first let me remind
you that you're going to die I know it's
really uplifting and it's really
exciting but the fact is that you're
gonna plotz and because you're going to
plot this is why you should be a
responsible adult and buy yourself some
life insurance the best way for you to
buy life insurance is to go to policy
genius policy genius has created a
website that makes it easy for you to
compare quotes get advice get covered
without extra fees or commissions sales
agents policy genius is indeed the
easiest way because you can just compare
quotes from top insurers it's
competitive do you find the coverage you
need at a price you can afford
from there you can apply online and the
advisers that policy genius will handle
all the red tape for you they'll even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company all part of that best price
guarantee and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy whether you're
shopping for disability insurance to
protect your income or homeowners
insurance or auto insurance they can
help you get covered fast so if you've
been intimidated or frustrated by
insurance in the past try starting your
search of policy genius calm in minutes
you can compare quotes and apply you me
the whole thing on your phone right this
very second in fact you probably should
whatever you're doing just take the
phone and go to policy genius com get
that life insurance cuz you don't know
what's gonna happen in the next five
minutes you could be electrocuted there
could be an asteroid that hits you
whatever make sure you have life
insurance policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again
that's policy genius calm they make it
easy for you to buy that life insurance
so you don't have to be worried about
being buried in a pauper's grave and
leaving your family bereft if god forbid
you were to die right now okay you
didn't die so you're still here so let's
talk about the news of the day so the
news of the day the big story that the
media are aghast over they are a gaga
over this story it is just it's a
shocking appalling story there are these
things these crazy people
they're called Christians and they exist
on mass in the United States there are
many of them as it turns out many many
Christians all across the United States
they're really weird these Christians
they go to things called churches which
is like a big building as a cross on top
you may have driven past you may have
seen it once in a while and at these
churches they go into the
and then they open a book and this book
is really thick has lots of words in it
and they're associated in sentences that
are called verses and they open this
book which I've heard is called the
Bible and they open it up and then they
read things in this Bible and they
actually believe the crazy things they
read in this Bible and if you are a
reporter you have never heard of these
things because these things are very bad
these things are like traditional
morality about sex which is really bad
because as we all know the only type of
sex that is bad the only type of sex
that is bad is the one that is not
physically pleasing all other sex is
good but traditional Christians don't
think that they actually think that
certain types of sex are sinful and
Christians think a lot of other weird
things too about like this weird sky God
and all that kind of stuff well the
reason that I bring this up is that CNN
reporters are now discovering that these
Christians exist and it's opened up a
whole new lens on the world for them
it's like they're walking around and
every day and it's like oh my god they
suddenly we realized that half the
population is vampires CNN reporter Kate
Bennett describes herself as on the flow
to speed meaning that she covers the
First Lady of the United States she's a
White House reporter for CNN
well she tweeted out about a story
yesterday about Karen pence no as we all
know when we think of the face of evil
we think of Karen pence the wife of my
pens clearly Edisto Lee dastardly
villain why because Karen pens taught in
a Christian school for 12 years and she
happens to be the wife of the VP she's
actually a very nice lady her kids are
delightful I've met her children I've
met the vice president as well she's a
nice lady but because she's a nice lady
that just shows she's even more evil why
because now she's going back to teaching
at a Christian school and she's teaching
at this Christian school which happens
to believe things that Christians have
believed for a couple of thousand years
which is breaking news to kate bennett
because the world started spinning when
kate Bennett was born apparently so
she'd tweeted out again she's a CNN
reporter so let me get this straight
the second lady of the United States has
chosen to work at a school that openly
discriminates against LGBT adults and
children well if this makes it sound
like is that Karen pence is like heading
on over to the local Sharia law school
and there she is teaching about the
evils of homosexuality that's not what's
happening she's an art teacher and she's
teaching at a traditional Christian
school this Christian school is very bad
though it's called the Emanuel Christian
school it enrolled kindergarten
through eighth graders at its campus in
Springfield Virginia and if you want to
go to the school you know voluntarily
like you it's a Christian school that
teaches Christian principles and if you
are a Christian who wants to voluntarily
attend this Christian school then you
have to sign an agreement that you are
going to abide by Christian standards of
conduct
now as a religious person as a religious
Jew we have exactly the same thing in
the Jewish community right I went to a
Jewish day school the Jewish day school
I went to it wasn't just that you had to
abide by particular standards of sexual
morality your your parents also had to
keep Sabbath you had to keep kosher
right at any of these voluntary
associations you actually have to abide
by the rules of the Association
shockingly voluntary associations you
actually have to abide by the rules of
the Association so what is so terrible
well in the articles of employment which
requires applicants to sign their
initials next to a list of beliefs
Emmanuel Christian defines marriage and
sexual identity it says I understand
that the term marriage has only one
meaning the uniting of one man and one
woman I know mind-blown
this is brand-new stuff to folks in the
media and it also adds that certain
moral misconduct would be disqualifying
for both students and teachers such as
heterosexual activity outside of
marriage like premarital sex
cohabitation extramarital sex homosexual
or lesbian sexual activity polygamy
transgender identity any other violation
of the unique rules of male and female
and so this is very bad it's absurd it's
just terrible because how could the non
elected vice president's wife go and
teach in a Christian school that
preaches actual like long lasting
traditional Christian values
it's just insane that you would actually
go teach at a Christian school now this
is called a Christian being a Christian
and doing Christian things in their
Christian life right this is just how
Christians operate in the daily world
traditional Christians and traditional
Jews operate in the daily world I've
only taught traditional Muslims operate
in the daily world right if you are a
religious person of any of the three
Abrahamic faiths and you are really
traditional in your religious observance
then all the things that I just listed
you also believe but this is really bad
according to Kate Bennett so she's a
reporter but she's never heard of a
religious person before she's a White
House reporter for CNN who has never
heard of a Christian breaking news Mike
Pence's wife who is a Christian is
working at a Christian school that
believes in Christian principles that
people can voluntarily associate with so
here's the question who's really
intolerant here who's the really
discriminatory person here Mike Pence's
wife who is joining a private school
that is privately funded and not
publicly funded and engaging and
voluntary Association that has nothing
to do with public policy or a CNN
reporter saying that Mike Pence's wife
is disgracing the country by doing this
no media bias by the way this is all
objective news journalism over at CNN
but this goes to a really difficult
issue for a lot of folks on the left and
that is a lot of folks on the Left
actually believe that religion itself
traditional religion itself in the
United States must be quashed in order
for freedom to reign not just on a legal
level but on a cultural level as well
people must be shamed for associating
with traditional religious organizations
so the New York Times which of course
was also shocked to learn about
religious people they quoted a woman
named Elizabeth Chapman her a professor
of politics and religion at Northwestern
University she said that the school's
requirements appeared more extreme than
other religious schools and noted that
not all Christians would agree with them
well no bleep Sherlock I mean of course
but some Christians agree with them
namely the Christians who are going to
the school and who fund the school and
who pay to go to the school and as far
as these requirements being more extreme
than other religious schools I like
seeing some poll data on that I would
bet you money at virtually every
Catholic school in the country has
extraordinarily similar requirements
every Orthodox school that I know of has
similar requirements and then this
professor says that mrs. pence choice of
employment was not surprising because
the schools values appeared to mirror
those of the Trump administration and
this is where they're really going right
the vice president's wife who is not
elected is teaching in a Christian
school that she taught at for a dozen
years before but now this is a
reflection on the Trump administration's
evil so professor Hurd says given the
exclusionary nationalism in this
administration clearly she is a
clear-eyed objective viewer of this
administration and sorts of politics
taken on various things it would not be
at all surprising for the second lady to
associate herself with some prominent
fashion with an institution like this it
raises important issues about education
and diversity and what kind of
forward-facing public officials we want
representing our country at home and
abroad again the application clearly
states that certain things are necessary
if you want to join
which is not a problem but here's the
thing what the left wants to do is shame
people into not being part of churches
right that's really what they want what
they want is that any time a public
figure is a member of a church unless
you're Barack Obama and you go to
Jeremiah Wright's church for twenty
years where he preaches outright hatred
of the United States hatred of Jews the
9/11 was the chickens coming home to
roost and then if you mentioned that by
the way that you're racist right if you
mentioned Jeremiah Wright a pastor so
close to Barack Obama that Barack Obama
literally named his second book The
Audacity of Hope after a speech called
The Audacity of Hope given by Jeremiah
Wright if you mention that you say well
maybe his ideas aren't linked to
Jeremiah Wright and somewhat they go no
that's his private religious belief how
dare you sir how dare you but if you
remember the Knights of Columbus then
mazie Hirono of Hawaii will come after
you the senator from Hawaii and if
you're Karen pence not even an elected
politician serving in the federal
government and you go to a Christian
school I go to a church then we're gonna
shame the living daylights out of you
now listen I think it's fair game to
criticize people's views you want to
criticize Karen pence as traditional
religious views go for it
you wanna criticize my traditional
religious views believe me I've had
plenty of people who have done it
I don't mind that's part of the
political back-and-forth and the
religious back-and-forth that we go
through every day in this country it's
part of what makes the country good is
that we can have these conversations but
to shame somebody as though they have
done something uniquely terrible by
going and teaching at a Christian school
is nothing but a cultural attempt to
quash religion itself and that cultural
attempt is not going to stay cultural
and it begins with it is culturally bad
it is just wrong on every level for
Karen pence to associate with a church
like this now it was funny is that
Bennett this was this reporter from CNN
then tweeted back at me and she said
well listen you know I'm really not all
that upset about religious freedom she
says I have absolutely nothing against
religious people or our freedom to
practice faith first of all both of
those statements are lies
obviously she doesn't like religious
people because if a religious person
believes something she doesn't like she
doesn't like what they're doing and she
says she's a she has nothing against
freedom to practice faith she literally
said that she found it appalling that
somebody was practicing their religious
faith because that's exactly what she's
talking about but then she continues but
I do feel when one is a representative
of the country a quick correction Karen
pence is not a representative of the
country she's not an elected
I know we play this stupid game where we
assume that the spouses of elected
officials are now elected officials I
know we've been doing this since Hillary
Clinton where we pretend oh well when
you elect Billie you get Hillary - and
you know what happened when Bill kept
saying that Hillary's approval rating
dropped to 30% for a first lady Michelle
Obama was really unpopular until she
realized wait a second I'm not an
elected official maybe I should stop
acting like an elected official
it really is it's an amazing thing but
in any case you know she did this this
this idea that Karen pence is
representative of the country and
therefore she's doing something deeply
wrong great great reporting there from
CNN okay in just a second in just a
second I want to talk a little bit about
how this is not gonna stay a cultural
issue this is gonna turn into a legal
issue quite quickly first we need to
talk about your underwear I know
hell of a transition Tommy John has the
most comfortable underwear for everyone
on the planet you can count on their
products to be snug and neat to stay in
one place their underwear sports no
wedgie guarantee comfortable stay put
waist bands and a range of fabrics that
are luxuriously soft designed to move
with you not against you that means
there's no bunching and no riding up
which would certainly help the reporters
over at CNN Plus Tommy John has a life
changing women's line and luxurious
hibernation prove loungewear for men and
women they're so confident in their
underwear that if you don't love your
first pair you can get a full refund
with their best pair you'll ever wear or
it's free guarantee so what do you got
to lose before you spend another dime on
multi pack underwear remember there's a
better way to stay comfortable Tommy
John no adjustment needed go check them
out right now at Tommy John comm / Ben
for 20% off your first order that's
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off again
Tommy John comm I'm wearing an underwear
right now I can I can speak to the
comfort of these things it's really
fantastic go check them out right now
they've bought a great products and you
get a special discount when you go to
Tommy John comm / Ben you get 20% off
again Tommy John comm / Ben go check
them out Tommy John calm okay so what
exactly is this cultural what is this
cultural rage going to turn into it's
going to turn into a legal attempt to
quash religion that is where this is
going it's already happening in New York
State now the way that folks on the Left
like to portray their attempted
crackdowns on religion is as
non-discrimination law they have all
these non-discrimination laws they've
been passing across the country with
these
say is that you are not allowed to
discriminate based on for example sexual
orientation now listen I'm not a
believer that you should discriminate on
the basis of sexual orientation when
you're running a business and we have
gay people who work at Daily wire I'm
sure there are gay people who work at
WABC like we don't care like no nobody
cares but in my synagogue it's a
different story
if the idea is that my synagogue has to
hire people who are homosexual or that
my synagogue has to perform same-sex
marriages or that it's going to lose its
nonprofit status or its tax-exempt
status then you have the state impinging
on religious freedom and that is where
all of this is going to go it's going to
start with the schools because the case
is going to be made and it already is
being made in the state of California
the idiotic state from which I hail it's
already being made there that if you
teach your children traditional morality
or damaging your children they're doing
something deeply wrong by teaching your
children traditional morality in fact
there's a guy named Angelo Curzon who's
the head of Media Matters for America
most famous for leading boycotts
nonsensically against various hosts he
was very angry at Karen pence and then
he suggested that Karen pence and
Christian parents are basically
indoctrinating their kids into bigotry
this is the case that's gonna be made by
a lot of folks on the Left that if you
bring up your kid in traditional
religious fashion then what you're
actually doing is damaging your own
child now he also was very angry that we
had a Lee Weyer had covered the story
where a ten-year-old boy was being
dressed in drag and then taking
photographs next to naked drag queens he
said we shouldn't have covered that that
was really that was really impending on
the rights of the parents so to get this
straight in his view dangerous is
pointing out that it's bad for parents
to dress their 10 year old boys and drag
and let them take pictures next to naked
men not but but what is what is really
really dangerous is that if you if you
have your kid go to a Bible class that's
that's really really scary stuff and so
how is this all gonna become enshrined
in law with first step is going to be
something like what New York State
passed this week so New York State
Senate passed this week a law banning
gay conversion therapy on minors this is
the way they pitch it so they pitched
the good parts of the law but they don't
pitch the entire law so the good parts
of the law is when they say that they
ban gay conversion therapy this is
basically a discredited evidence free
version of you're going to turn a
homosexual person straight or something
by talking to them there's not a lot of
evidence that any of that works with
that said in a free country if I decide
that I want to take my 13 year
boy to see a therapist and the therapist
wants to talk about the kids sexual
orientation and whether the kid might be
confused about sexual orientation I
don't see why that should be illegal I
think that's a vast overstep just from a
libertarian perspective not even from a
traditionalist perspective okay but
let's say that you think that that
should be illegal that's not all the law
does okay the state legally declared
that being lesbian gay bisexual or
transgender is not a disease that
disorder illness deficiency or
shortcoming I'm not sure how you can by
law declare that being transgender is
not a disorder it is literally called
gender identity disorder I don't know
how you can do that but it goes even
further than that it bans people we
talked about this yesterday on the radio
show it bans people who are therapists
from discussing gender dysphoria with
people in any honest way so if you have
a ten-year-old kid who comes in and says
I know I'm a biological boy but I'm
actually a girl on the inside you as a
therapist say well you know let's think
this one through you could be guilty of
violating the law in New York State okay
the same agenda is going to be pressed
down on these various schools so take
this law and see how it applies to a
manual Christian school that the school
where Karen Pence is teaching the law
prevents you from discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation it also
prevents you from suggesting in any way
that a biological male is a biological
male and a biological female is a
biological female because transgenderism
is just the natural state of the world
okay the way this is gonna be used as
number one they will remove the
tax-exempt status for all religious
organizations across the country that is
the way the left is moving and they will
use as their sort of test case the Bob
Jones University case from 1981 so
there's a very famous Supreme Court case
Bob Jones University in which the IRS
decided that they were going to remove
the tax-exempt status for Bob Jones
University Bob Jones University had a
very stupid policy that bans interracial
dating and the IRS said that's really
bad we're going to end their tax-exempt
status now it may be really bad and
maybe you need Congress to rewrite the
statutes but the IRS didn't have the
statutory authority to just say that
things that are bad no longer get
tax-exempt status but the Supreme Court
ruled that because Bob Jones was
discriminatory
therefore the tax-exempt status could be
removed once these non-discrimination
bills are passed in states across the
country the next move will be to go to
all these religious institutions and say
to them that you must accept same-sex
marriages being performed from your
but you must accept gay lesbian bisexual
transgender teachers at your religious
school and if you don't then you will
lose it not only our nonprofit status
but your accreditation and once you lose
your nonprofit status and your
accreditation your kids are gonna have
to go to the local public school and if
you decide to home-school them then we
are not going to allow you to
home-school them unless you fulfill our
certain basic educational requirements
this is the direction in which the left
is moving and it is open discrimination
and to pretend that it is not is foolish
the people who are cramming down their
values at this point are not religious
theocrats religious theocrats are not
cramming down their values Mike Pence is
not attempting to make homosexual
activity illegal I can't name a
Republican across the country who is
none of them are Republicans across the
country are not trying to imprison
people who are transgender no one is
doing this now people who are trying to
impinge on the rights and freedoms of
others are the people in the secular
left world who have decided that
religion itself is discriminatory and
infringes freedom this has always been
by the way the way that religious
minorities are persecuted the way that
religious minorities are persecuted in
countries across the world is that they
run up against the prevailing social
order and that social order is allowed
to step on the minorities that are
infringing what the social order is
attempting to do and it's why it's
whether that discrimination is coming
from Islamic tyrannies in the Middle
East or whether that discrimination is
coming from European states that are
attempting to crush Christianity it does
not matter if you are attempting to
crush private religious practice that
has no impact on public policy because
you don't like that religious practice
you are a bigot and you're a tyrant and
that is the direction that the modern
American Left is moving it's it's
astonishing it's astonishing there's a
reason by the way that Christianity
around the world is suffering a huge
increase in in persecution and you've
seen that the Chinese government has
been particularly active in trying to
quash religious freedom in China because
tyrannies recognized the rebellion that
exists within those tyrannical societies
generally comes from religious people
who believe in individual rights and
families and thus you have to have China
cracking down what's been amazing is to
watch Western secular companies
basically be okay with that they're
doing the work of China you got Google
it's actually tailoring its apps for
Chinese use without reference to the
human rights violations that are taking
place in China
it's pretty amazing and pretty
frightening and again we should take it
seriously when the left says that they
don't like religion because they mean it
they mean it by the way they don't like
Western civilization either the term
Western civilization there's an actual
op-ed in the Washington Post today by
David Perry and Matthew Gabriel
suggesting that the term Western
civilization is itself racist so they
say that because Steve King once use the
term Western civilization Western
civilization like the term is racist
which means that we have to ban the term
Western civilization or at least pretend
the Western civilization no longer holds
the truth is that a lot of the
objections to Christianity and
judeo-christian values and Western
civilization are built on a Marxist
premise that America and Western
civilized countries are inherently
racist sexist bigoted homophobic and
must be torn out by the roots so
Christianity has to go because it's
bigoted even though Christianity by the
way the Christian world is the basis for
all the rights and freedoms that you
enjoy today I don't care whether you are
secular I don't care whether you're
religious we live in a world defined by
the judeo-christian ethic that's what
made the West different from every other
place on planet Earth and to pretend
that that ethic was completely thrown
out with the Enlightenment and what the
Enlightenment was about was saying
churches are wrong we're just not gonna
do Church anymore that is to ignore the
fact that virtually every value that we
hold dear is rooted in a judeo-christian
tradition the most important sentence
ever written in the history of humanity
is that man is made in God's image it is
the beginning and end point of virtually
all moral arguments that is an argument
that is made by the judeo-christian
religion the argument for personal
liberty that you have inherent rights
the argument that virtue matters so that
we can have freedom all of this arises
in Western civilization defined by these
values so if you wanted to do away with
those values if he wanted the collective
to be more important than the individual
the best way to do it would be to attack
Christianity and Judaism at their roots
would be to attack religion and tear
those away and again although the ironic
part of this is that this is the least
threatening time for theocracy in world
history at least from the
judeo-christian side and we're being
treated as though Karen Pence's the true
threat to Liberty Karen Penn's not the
not the Democrats we're attempting to
stop judges from being appointed to the
bench based on their membership in the
Knights of Columbus okay in just a
second I want to talk a little bit about
the latest from Rudy Giuliani but first
I need to talk to you about the watch
that you're wearing he's that thing on
your wrist it's ugly
I don't know why you're wearing it you
shouldn't be wearing it what you should
be wearing it's a movement watch because
movement watches are great you see the
what you see the sleek elegant thing on
my wrist you see this it's magnificent
hey that is a movement watch movement is
a grounds of entrepreneurial company a
true success story they have sold
legitimately hundreds of thousands of
watches there's a reason I have a
movement watch my wife has one
both my parents have one they make great
gifts and what's great is that they cut
out the middleman
these aren't watches that are by the way
going to tell you how many steps you
take or how many calories you burn
these are watches that are going to tell
you the time and they're going to do it
in an elegant sleek fashion these
watches start at like 95 bucks you're
looking at 400 bucks for the same
quality from a traditional brand because
they cut out the middleman they were
able to sell it cheaper online movement
has sold almost 2 million watches in
over 160 countries and right now you get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns just by going to MVM t.com
slash shapiro again that is MBM t.com
slash pure you get 15% off today they've
all sorts of other great products they
have like sunglasses and and they have
bracelets all sorts of good stuff go
check them out MVM t.com slash is
shapiro once again MVM t.com slash
shapiro ok so meanwhile in in more
political news Rudy Giuliani made a bit
of a boo-boo today so the president's
lawyer Rudy Giuliani has the hardest job
in America there are two the two hardest
jobs in America are being the person who
cleans up after pop stars at hotels and
being and being Donald Trump's and being
down from some lawyer that's it that is
a rough job as a lawyer there are
certain clients that you just dread and
Donald Trump is that client because the
first rule of wiring is you tell your
client to shut up that legitimately is
like the first written no matter what
the situation the first rule of wiring
is cut off all communications between
you and the other side on camera we're
talking transactional law or criminal
law but particularly when you are in the
midst of a massive counterintelligence /
criminal investigation into Russian
collusion first rule tell your client to
shut up second rule your client actually
has to tell you the truth so that you
can form a legal strategy around it
third rule is don't say stupid stuff on
TV all three of these rules are
routinely violated by president Trump's
legal team so Rudy Giuliani was on CNN
yesterday with Chris Cuomo a physical
block of wood and he was explaining to
Chris Cuomo that President Trump
personally did not collude with Russia
but
maybe somebody did which is like dude
dude like what now I think they're there
those of us have been saying no evidence
of collusion for a long time
you kind of switch in the story on us a
little bit here's what Rudy Giuliani had
to say never said there was no collusion
between the campaign or between people
in the campaign I have not I said the
president United States there is not a
single bit of evidence the president
United States committed the only crime
you could admit here conspired with the
Russians to half the dancing he said he
didn't he didn't say nobody how would
you know that nobody in your camp he
actually did say that Rudy he said I
don't I said as far as I am well as far
as he knows that's true now rule that
there's part of what really saying
that's probably true and part of what
are you saying that is certainly Falls
the part that he's saying that certainly
false is when he says that Trump didn't
say that nobody colluded with the
Russians no Trump actually has said that
like Trump actually has said my campaign
did not collude with the Russians nobody
colluded with it like collusion wasn't a
thing
so that's but at this point are we like
surprised the Trump didn't tell the
truth about that kind of thing that he
overstated his case this is a guy who
said he didn't sleep with stormy Daniels
he I'm sorry the President of the United
States does not make good legal defenses
of himself because he just says whatever
comes into his head at any given moment
but the peril Rudi has a defensible
truth it's ugly but it's defensible is I
think the case he's gonna make and this
sort of looks forward to the Muller
report the case that he's probably going
to make is that is that the President of
the United States didn't personally know
about anything the people in his
campaign who were doing bad stuff were
acting outside the scope of agency in
other words they were just kind of
acting out on their own so manna fort
was freelancing and when he was talking
with the Russians maybe that's a case
but dude don't spill that on national TV
not the way to do it so even as Rudy
Giuliani stumbles out the gate when
talking about the Muller investigation
the good news is for the Republicans
that the Democrats are not doing
themselves any favor bado O'Rourke today
I will say the Democrats have been
totally taken over by the social media
wing of their party now as a big user of
social media I'm fond of social media
but social media isn't necessarily the
best way to weed out deep thinkers
there's a reason that Alexander Ocasio
Cortes is about to teach I kid you not a
session
- older lawmakers on how to tweet sure
this according to USA Today the House
Democratic policy and Communications
Committee is hosting a session Thursday
morning with Ocasio Cortez on the most
effective ways to engage constituents on
Twitter and the importance of digital
storytelling rule number one be a pretty
young woman I mean that and then when if
you can't fulfill rule number one then
you're basically you're screwed at that
point I mean if you're a Democrat and
you're 70 years old you're not gonna get
good at social media anytime soon what's
made her popular on social media is the
fact that she is likable on social media
she is sassy on social media and of
course she's pretty so that does make a
difference but she's teaching Democrats
the most important things in life how to
be good on social media beta O'Rourke
meanwhile is running for president he's
pulling number two in a lot of these
polls it's showing Biden and then beta
O'Rourke and Biden seems to be dropping
by the day because he's old and boring
Boehner O'Rourke is the hot new thing
because he rides a skateboard and
because he has like a big he has bangs
on his face and just kind of flicks his
hair back because he's cool so he has a
piece today in medium.com I love that
this guy's one of the frontrunners I
love it so much Bob O'Rourke so he's got
a he's got a piece in medium talking
about his travels and he is essentially
skater boy Jack Kerouac that's that's
what he's going for here I'm gonna read
some of this to you because it is worthy
of note I mean it isn't really but the
fact that he wrote it makes it worthy of
note here is what he writes he writes a
lot of big trucks rolling down pancake
Boulevard and there aren't any sidewalks
gloomy early morning sky in liberal
Kansas snowmelt on the side of the road
where I'm running I find a vacant lot to
cut through to another Street also busy
and without sidewalks I was in Tucumcari
yesterday trying to learn more about the
town and my great-grandparents lived in
more than a hundred years ago I stayed
at the motel Safari one of these classic
route 66 motels mid-century everything
take a break come back stronger I'm not
kidding you this is a presidential
candidate who wrote these things and
he's being treated by the media it's
like wow what depth what what thoughts
emerged from the massive brains
Christian simple-minded beta O'Rourke
super deep that the best part is when he
starts talking about his own personal
attitude he says the next morning I
just a couple of miles down 66 then
through neighborhoods past the History
Museum my leg has been really bothering
me since the campaign and so I'd stopped
running for a while
this is my first one in more than a
month felt good running in new shoes
have been stuck lately in and out of a
funk my last day of work was January 2nd
it's been more than 20 years since I was
last not working maybe if I get moving
on the road meet people Lord about
what's going on where they live have
some adventure go where I don't know and
I'm not known it'll clear my head reset
I'll think new thoughts break out of
loops I've been stuck in heels like 17
hey I'm just a god it's like going on a
European backpacking trip it's amazing
he sounds like Timothy Treadwell right
before he got eaten by bears and grizzly
man I'm gonna go up to Alaska living a
bus talk to the Bears find myself if my
kidneys are clawed out of me well that's
just the way it goes man that's the
price of adventure and then he talked
about all the people that means this
thing is thousands of words long
thousands because he just has this kind
of genius to convey to you it's amazing
I'm scrolling I'm still scrolling I'm
still scrolling and he finally concludes
by saying a young woman asked how do I
make a difference in any of this I said
run for office hold town hall meetings
bring people together over coffee over
beer ask your elected representative
primary continues apace and it really
astonishing stuff from bado O'Rourke I
mean when he's not when he's not
actually taping his when he's not busy
taping his dental appointments
apparently he is busy running around and
and writing about his experiences in
Texas he must have been the worst in
high school right and like he's the
worst now so they must be the worst in
high school also okay in a second I want
to talk a little bit more about the
various Democratic candidates who are
being upheld by the media I'll get to
that in just second plus the Democrats
trying to push off the State of the
Union address what that is really about
we'll get to all that first you're gonna
have to go to Facebook and subscribe you
want to see the rest of this show live
you want to actually view this massively
handsome face go check it out a daily
walk
calm for the rest of the show when you
subscribe to get the rest of the show
live I get the rest of Michael Moses
show live you get the rest of Andrew
Clavin show live plus when you subscribe
you also get two additional hours do a
live radio show in the afternoons and
you actually get to see that and you get
to do it on demand you get to see it
without commercials but only if you
subscribe when you spend 99 bucks a year
you also got our famous leftist cheers
hot or cold tumblr when we're on the
road we activate the invisibility button
so I'm holding it up right here but you
can't see it because that's just how
magical it is you can check that out
when you get the annual subscription
also reminder tomorrow the Ben Shapiro
show will be live at the March for Life
in Washington DC at 10:00 a.m. Eastern
I'll be live-streaming at the National
Mall on 12th Street so if you're
planning to go to the March come out and
hang out the show's gonna be entirely
about pro-life topics we're gonna do a
themed show which we never do but the
March for Life is a really important
thing we will also have a special guest
who will be on the show so you're not
gonna want to miss that also I have lots
of announcements I'm kicking off and I
spring 2019 young America's Foundation
tour with my latest event at George
Washington University the speech is
called
your free stop whining so tune in at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific at yah org
slash live so you don't miss out on any
of the melting of the leftist snowflakes
that is sure to come this is where all
the Ben Shapiro destroys videos come
from I'm not gonna say we're behind them
because we're only behind some of them
but the reality is if you want to see
that happen live in real time you have
to go to ya org slash well I've also
subscribes that you get these Sunday
special we have Lieutenant Colonel Alan
West on at YouTube iTunes subscribe
thanks so much for all your hope we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so it's not just Pater or
work who is being given the king's
treatment by the media it's also Kamala
Harris who is really I find her
radically unlikable I know I'm not
supposed to say that it is super sexist
if you say that a woman is unlikable it
is pretty much the most sexist thing you
can say about a woman is that she is
unlikable like that time that Barack
Obama said that Hillary Clinton was
unlikable that was super sexist Oh Carla
Harris I don't find particularly likable
but the media are trying super hard to
sell her like really hard by the way I
always find it weird when people say
unlikable sexist term have you met Ted
Cruz like really like I I know senator
Cruz I like senator Cruz in prison come
off great on camera there's certain
likability factor that just matters in
politics in any case ABC News has an
entire piece today on her it's ABC News
really journalism everywhere and it's
it's incredible it's from Good Morning
America listen to this headline this is
a news headline this is not a teen beat
headline celebrities they're just like
us headline here's the actual headline
potential 2020 presidential candidate
Kamala Harris shares advice for young
women don't let anybody tell you who you
are you tell them who you are that's a
headline a news headline I know it's
been a real problem for me is when I
walk up to people and I just say Bob I'm
because like no I'm Jim I'm like no I'm
gonna tell you who you are you're Bob
that's that's been a real problem in
fact I actually do this every day when I
go to the coffee shop I don't let them
tell me who I am
I tell them who I am so they can write
it on the cup and then I can get my
coffee she is just the most
platitudinous politician in the world my
favorite quote from this interview that
ABC News is touting is quote if it's
worth fighting for then it's a fight
worth having okay okay if the sky is
blue then it is also blue and then she
like it's just a list I actually listed
it out on my Twitter feed this morning
she dropped no less than 13 platitudes
in the course of an interview every
sentence she said was a platitude every
single one she actually says things like
she's asked for advice here's a piece of
advice for young woman you ready for
this this is groundbreaking this is the
kind of stuff that ought to make you
president this is groundbreaking advice
for young women according to Good
Morning America quote surround yourself
with really good friends
groundbreaking advice from the
running presidential candidate Kamala
Harris she says it's really important
because none of us have achieved the
success we have without really good
friends mind blown
and my I don't know say about that it's
just the genius roles offer in waves
pretty amazing okay I want to give you a
quick update on the Steve King story
because I wanna get to the State of the
Union stuff in a second but the Steve
King story is is pretty is pretty
telling and this is an update
hey the Steve King story as you all know
representative Steve King from Iowa he
was asked he actually asked in a New
York Times interview how the terms white
nationalists and white supremacists
became offensive right according to the
New York Times and a bunch of
Republicans and Democrats looked to
censor Steve King a bunch of them look
to censure him for his racial Commons so
what did Democrats do did they vote for
the center they run the house after all
so why didn't they just vote for the
center instead House Democratic leaders
blocked an effort to censure Steve King
for racial Commons they referred the
measure to the House Ethics Committee
for further review why would they do
such a thing don't they hate racist
comments well it turns out what they are
afraid of is that if they censure Steve
King they are also going to have to
start censoring the other members of
their own caucus for saying racist stuff
really I'm not saying this they are
saying this Jim Clyburn admitted as much
Clyburn who's the House Majority Whip
he noted that King made his statements
to the news media not during House
proceedings he said I don't know it's a
good thing for us to talk about censure
for things that are done outside the
business of the House of Representatives
he said we should be very very careful
about doing anything that constrains or
seems to constrain speech I know
Democrats are deeply concerned about
doing anything that might constrain
speech is one of their chief concerns in
life which is why they promote hate
speech laws and why they talk about
microaggressions and intersectionality
endlessly and then Bobby Rush ripped
into ripped into Clyburn he said that
cleburn's disapproval resolution was
almost meaningless but Clyburn says
listen here's the problem if we Center
Steve King how many of you have been
saying nice things about Louis Farrakhan
for years how many of you have been
saying bad things about Jews like today
representative Johanna Omar who's an
anti-semite when on CNN and not only did
she double down on her anti-semitism she
also suggested in an open national
interviews to become the second
democratic representative to do this in
the last day that Lindsey
was being blackmailed by President Trump
because Lindsey Graham is gay and she
said that in an interview on CNN then
when she was asked about it she said
many people are saying now I'm old
enough to remember when many people are
saying was used as a way to Club
President Trump this is what Trump does
all the time right
Trump says something that's unsupported
or unsupportable and then when asked if
that's true he goes many people die
saying it's what many people say and
people like well who are these people
are they you and this is but Democrats
are now allowed to do this but what
Clyburn is afraid of is that he might
actually have to censure his own members
because they say crazy stuff too
turns out that when you have a group of
435 people they're a bunch of people who
say crazy stuff in there but I love the
I love the cynicism of Democrats so
angry at Steve King that they will not
censure him because they might have to
censure members of their own caucus for
being terrible but at the same time we
are told by people like Nicole Wallace
at MSNBC that really the racism problem
only exists on the Republican side of
the aisle the Democrats are clean as the
driven snow they have nothing to worry
about
even the Democrats think the Democrats
have something to worry about even the
Democrats think that they might have to
censor their own members really is
amazing stuff okay well latest on the on
the government shutdown it continues of
course and this means that the Democrats
now have an excuse to cancel the State
of the Union address as I pointed out
yesterday I could not be happier with
this frankly like I am so excited I
don't have to cover the State of the
Union address I can barely speak about
it it makes me so happy
I hate the State of the Union address
with a deep abiding passion because it
is monarchic it is just terrible
you have the president walk in as though
he's the crown prince of England and
then everybody Pat's him on the back and
they take selfies with him and then
they'll stand in sheer oh you're the
president okay when the Constitution was
written it was legislature that was
supposed to be the predominant branch of
government not the executive yet we
treat the executive as though it is the
predominant branch of government and the
state of the union was made into a giant
speech by Woodrow Wilson because Woodrow
Wilson was in fact a quasi fascist who
liked that sort of spectacle hey well if
we get rid of the State of the Union I'm
gonna be super happy I think president
Trump's you just do it directly from the
border you declare state of the union
invite all the members of Congress they
can come down to the border the ones who
want to the ones you don't don't have to
and then you can just bring up angel
mom's and Border Patrol members I think
I'd be great I think you should totally
do that
but then
Kratts the real reason they don't want
to do the State of the Union it's
amazing how they even lie about this in
the real reason they don't want to do
the State of the Union has nothing to do
with inability to do it it's because
they don't want the imagery of President
Trump lecturing them about keeping the
government shot so Nancy Pelosi just
lied about it yesterday the Speaker of
the House she said the reason that we
can't do the State of the Union is
because it won't be safe here's a
speaker over the house explaining that
one yesterday I think at the point the
point is security and I and having been
in a leadership a long time have been
maybe before you were all here where
they have we have so prepared in advance
for something happening in that chamber
this is a very big deal it was a special
security event okay so she says that
it's because of security that is
absolutely false the Department of
Homeland Security had Milson she says of
course we can support the State of the
Union of course we can like what you
think we don't have security like at the
Congress now she tweeted out of this
Christian Nielsen's she tweeted up the
Department of Homeland Security and the
US Secret Service are fully prepared to
support and secure the State of the
Union we thanked the service for their
mission focus and dedication and for all
they do each day to secure our homeland
okay it's obviously an excuse it's
obviously an excuse so that Nancy Pelosi
does not have to sit there well Trump
points to angel mom's in the crowd and
says why don't you defend this angel mom
why don't you defend this wounded person
why don't you defend this victim of
illegal immigration they're attempting
to avoid the consequences of their own
position on the government shutdown it
is indicative of how people in the
Democratic Party treat national security
and security issues generally so what
they say is that there doesn't need to
be a wall Border Patrol is saying yeah
guys there does and then they're like
well you know what Homeland Security
probably can't do the State of the Union
and homeland skiers like no actually we
kind of can and they say things like
well the military doesn't need x y&z and
members of the military say well no
actually we could probably use those
things and then they expect us to
believe that we tended they take
security seriously it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous the real reason that Pelosi
is not doing the State of the Union is
because she doesn't want to be
humiliated on a public stage which is
the same reason why she's refusing to
meet with the angel moms yesterday bunch
of angel moms went to Nancy Pelosi's
office and she refused to come out or
speak with them because why would she
mean she understands how optics
work by Elham Arabi needs more than you
care about the illegal aliens crossing
our borders right these children had
dreams every one of these kids had a
dream and they've been crushed your
actions still matter take my son's life
be worth more than $1 and that's an
insult to all of us yeah there's a
reason that I suppose he doesn't want to
show up because obviously she
understands how optics works and I will
point out the amount of media coverage
for the angel mom's went to Nancy
Pelosi's office was not nearly the
amount of media coverage for the for
Democratic Congress people who went and
searched for Mitch McConnell yesterday
so there were four Democratic Congress
people they went to Mitch McConnell's
office and they showed up north where's
Mitch McConnell where's Mitch McConnell
first of all Mitch McConnell is trying
to work out his next cocaine shipment
right he's cocaine Mitch we know what
he's doing with his off hours but second
of all why would he come out and meet
with like Alexandra Ocasio Cortez if I
were Mitch McConnell I would but that's
cuz I'm confrontational I think would
just be great
for Mitch McConnell to walk out just
being all laconic and have her shout in
his face and just be Greg that's how
that dynamic would go she'd get very
upset she'd start yelling at him Aloha
Nomar would start yelling at him and he
would just stand there and take it and
it would be really amusing he'd just be
like well you guys could just fun the
border you know and in his turtle voice
and it would be great like I actually
think that more confrontation with
Democrats on this issue is is necessary
but McConnell is not famous for being
confrontational with that said the State
of the Union excuses that are being made
right now are obviously horrendous
excuses and do not reflect reality in
any serious way it's just another way
for Democrats to try and get out of this
and this is the benefit of being able to
run on on the media's love the polls
show right now that the media the me
that basically most Americans think that
Congress is doing a bad job think Obama
I think that Trump is doing a bad job
that plurality of Americans a slight
minority of Americans rather are in
support of the wall and that trumps
approval ratings are really low so all
Democrats have to do is stay out of the
limelight just keeps shouting Trump what
Trump has to do is shift the narrative
that's very difficult to do in the face
of a Democratic Party overwhelmingly
united by their hatred of him what was
so terrible about border fencing six
years ago nothing what's so terrible
about border fencing now Trump's the
president so that's what's terrible
inherently about border fencing
which is the reason that they keep doing
this routine it's really amazing I do
love the pitch the Democrats are making
as to why the government shutdown is bad
though that I will say I find amusing so
on the one side you have Trump saying we
need border security so we can ensure
that people don't get killed and on the
other side Bernie Sanders legitimately
legitimately went outside the EPA he
stood outside the EPA he said we need
the government shutdown to end because
of climate change like of all the
government services that are urgent to
provide the EPA administrators are the
ones they're not even the ones doing the
climate change research they're the
regulators that like if they're gone for
a week nobody notices
in fact if they're gone forever nobody's
gonna notice except they'll be able to
actually build things on their own
property but Bernie thinks that that's
the real priority the difference in
priorities is what Democrats are deeply
afraid of
it's what President Trump has to keep
hammering and it's what the media will
refuse to cover so that that's the real
reason why Democrats are trying to run
away
desperately from the State of the Union
address they don't actually want Trump
to have a public opportunity to show
them up okay time for a couple of things
I like and then we'll do some things
that I hate so things I like today this
year marks the 20th anniversary of The
Sopranos so I will admit that the first
time around I was a little too young to
watch The Sopranos I've been real
watching it and it is obviously really
r-rated it's a very r-rated show but it
is also a terrific show I mean the way
that it is written it's a beautifully
written show it's well acted James
Gandolfini is terrific in the show and
there's a shockingly moral undercurrent
to the show
which is that if you are an evil person
who justifies evil acts yourselves there
are serious consequences to that here's
a little bit of the trailer for the
original Sopranos but a time I was a kid
I know I've run a family business celina
human waste management consultant
[Music]
it's a gift from Tony Soprano are you in
the Mafia this is overdue by you know
what like my uncle ran it like my father
ran it hide running so the show the show
is really good and people glorify in
sort of gangster movies you can stop it
there
people people glorify in gangster movies
specifically because they sort of live
vicariously through the characters if
there were no moral rules then this is
what we would do with our free time we
would all be gangsters and we run around
at strip clubs and blow things up which
is why you actually do need a moral
Society so the the the subversive
undercurrent of this show is that the
guys in The Godfather that are actually
bad guys and that the guys in The
Sopranos are actually bad guys so it's
it's worth the watch if you've never
seen it and if you can handle you know
graphic violence and nudity but you're
an American so you probably can okay
time for some things that I hate
okay so thing I hate number one Stephen
Colbert is just a hack dude's a hack
okay so Stephen Colbert is it's funny to
me that there are certain people who
feel they need to pretend this even
Colbert is funny like as a political
stance oh we have to pretend people are
funny now we have to pretend Hannah
Gadsby is funny the least funny human
being maybe ever to walk the planet it's
it's legitimately between like her and a
third century priest for the if we a
heads it like history of the plan at
least funny people Hannah Gadsby 3rd
century priest that's pretty much those
are pretty much the contenders and then
we also have to pretend that like
Samantha bee is funny Samantha bee
hasn't told a joke in several years
there was a point when Samantha bee was
funny and then being the hope of the the
woke Queen I went to her head and then
Jimmy Kimmel used to be a lot more funny
and then being the woke Pope went to his
head well Stephen Colbert put out a
tweet this morning and says we got our
hands on Trump's handwritten State of
the Union address okay
if you were a child and you were making
a joke about this what joke would you
make
what would the punchline be the
punchline would be a badly spelled
Krantz crawling right I mean that's that
would be the punchline that's the most
obvious punchline in the world what do
you think Stephen Colbert tweeted out a
Krantz crawled poorly spelled letter I
mean and here's what it says dearest
America because and it's funny because
like some of the EES are backwards and
stuff the state of our onion is strong
like my boss crossed out friend Putin in
collusion
conclusion builds wall eat hamburger Don
et u.s. Prez somewhere somewhere all the
clowns weep somewhere all the comedians
roll over in their graves somewhere
comedy shrieks its final cry to the sky
and dies as Stephen Colbert beats it to
death with an axe and buries it in a
cornfield in Iowa because my goodness it
but it that sound importance not funny
that he doesn't have to be funny he just
has to be correct politically that's the
only thing that matters okay speaking of
people who are out of their mind
and I'm not sure where they're trying
comedy or not so People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals it as somebody who
actually is sort of friendly to animal I
won't say animal rights but to to humane
treatment of animals I'm very friendly
to humane treatment of animals arguments
I've said before I think there's
actually not indecent case for
vegetarianism or even veganism
especially as we develop alternative
sources of food especially as we develop
ways to get the protein that we need
without killing animals like I'm
actually kind of friendly to that
argument PETA is insane like the people
the people for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals I could construct a group that
would make people want to eat meat it
would be People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals it's unbelievable
and all they do full-time full-time is
you shoot themselves in both feet and
then they look down and if there's any
toes left they continue to pull the
trigger until all toes have been
obliterated
so Peter put out an ad yesterday based
on the the toxic masculinity nonsense
that's going around the internet in
which I even hesitate to show this
because it's just that bad in which I
could do not they strapped certain
vegetables to the genital area of
unattractive men and then say that
veganism makes men more virile so with
that introduction you've been warned so
if you want to close your eyes now if
you're a subscriber or if you wish to
fast-forward beyond this you have my
permission because it's horrifying my
retinas have already been scorched by
this stuff I can't unsee so I've already
I've already viewed this and now it
can't be unseen I warn you now if you
have an innocent mind if you are a
person of decent moral character protect
you protect thy self but if you're just
too curious based on this pitch which is
probably the guys then
you gaze upon in horror the works of man
[Music]
that is a carrot that is doubling as
man's genitals okay and it goes on like
this for like two minutes
just people dancing with like eggplant
strapped to their genitals and the case
that they are making is that you
shouldn't eat meat because vegetables
make more virile well if the case is
that you should be more virile like
these guys there will never be another
man who needs a vegetable ever because
these get I mean nothing has made me
want to eat fruits and vegetables less
than this commercial this is it's just
one fight now all that matters online is
they get attention so Peter is just
trolling for attention obviously you
please stop it please for the love of
God stop it please stop it that's enough
okay thank you if PETA want again it
just goes to show you that we now live
in a world where trolling is everything
so PETA is not going to convince anyone
I have to imagine they know they're not
gonna convince anyone with this then
nobody was sitting around going you know
what I wanted to eat chicken tonight but
now that I've seen this beta soy boy
walking around with giant carrots
strapped to his pants
now I'm from now on I'm its salads for
me like apena knows that that's not
what's happening right I mean so PETA
realizes that but what they're doing is
they're servicing their base everything
in politics has become fanservice
President Trump isn't a fanservice
Alexandre Ocasio cortes into fanservice
PETA is into fanservice Gillette is into
fanservice now listen I'm in a business
where fanservice matters but if you are
a decent person then you might want to
spend a little bit more time thinking
less about fanservice and more about how
you convince people like if your actual
mission as PETA is to get people to stop
eating meat then maybe the best way to
get people to stop eating meat is to
make the case that people should just be
more humane and that doesn't mean saying
that eating chicken is a holocaust on
your plate which is something that PETA
said and then they had pictures of like
chickens in in cages as though a chicken
is a Jew right that's not going to
convince anybody but when nobody's
focused on convincing anymore right now
everybody is focused very much on
pointing fingers at each other and and
yelling as loudly as as possible that's
really the only thing that matters in
the world right now okay
the one other thing that I hate and I
would be remiss too
to skip it tonight there's a story about
Michael Cohen that I don't know whether
to love it or hate it because it's
pretty glorious I will admit Michael
Cohen the president's former personal
attorney so his new one is really
Giuliani as I've said this is the worst
job in the world Michael Cohen also had
one of the worst jobs in the world he
was the president's personal attorney
but when the president was not
presidents that meant he was basically
his payoff man apparently he hired an IT
firm to rig early drudge polls and CNBC
polls to favor president Trump but
that's not the only thing that he hired
the IT firm to do Michael Cohen also
hired the IT firm to set up a women for
Cohen page I kid you not a women for
Cohen page that portrayed him as a sexy
sexy man he this is what the daily beast
reports okay so it says that Michael
Cohen hired an IT firm to rig online
polls in favor of President Trump and he
instructed the company to create the at
women for Cohen Twitter account to loud
how sexually attractive he is according
to The Wall Street Journal from then
attorney promised to pay 50 grand to a
small tech firm run by a Liberty
University staffer to help distort
online polls at CNBC and Drudge Report
Cohen has confirmed the bombshell report
but the only really interesting part of
the report is that he felt the need to
create a women for Cohen Twitter
accounts in May 2016 the Twitter account
heralded Cohen as a sex symbol I kid you
not it says that this is a little
caption that he paid them to set up
women who love and support Michael Cohen
this thing had like a follower women who
and it was and as I assume his wife but
I have no idea said women who love and
support Michael Cohen strong pit bull
sex symbol no-nonsense business oriented
and ready to make a difference women for
Kony had them set that up in May 2016
with pay just shows you the lengths that
human beings will go for attention and
love they'll even make up groups about
how sexy they are I mean first of all
there are those of us who are enough to
pay to make up groups like that Michael
Khan but second of all but really you're
gonna sit I can't the president does not
surround himself with all the best
people that's all that's all I can say
the president isn't it his brag that all
the recipe it's only the butt no no he
does not have all the best people and it
has been a problem all righty well we
will be back here a little bit late
with our live daily show so you can
check that out if you're a subscriber if
not then you can listen to us tomorrow
we'll see you then this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19